explain to a child that someone
deliberately tried to kill him
from what the doctor said he has many
years of physiotherapy ahead of him and
we have no prospects or plan for the
future
other than being by his side months of
pain fear and rehabilitation hours and
days spent without talking without
moving without eating away from his home
away from his friends and away from his
family since mid-january our son could
eat again which has been an important
turning point for him and for us now
that the feeding tube doesn't bother him
anymore he can speak a little he's
obviously still very tired
speaks very little sparing his words and
remains very weak he is still in a
wheelchair today wear splints on his
left arm and both his legs and spends
his days in a corset molded to his body
so he molded his waist sat in his
wheelchair the nights are always
extremely difficult his sleep is very
agitated he is in pain he wakes up many
times and he cries months on from the
attack we have been living out of our
home unable to see any loved one apart
from those who come to visit our son and
unable to spend quality time with our
son at Christmas
everything is constrained by his care
and the hospital as well as the
recurring pain our child is suffering
from there are no words to express what
we are going through and even upon
rereading the information provided here
we feel that it does not reflect the
reality of our situation nor the
difficulties and pain we're currently
experiencing thank you very much well
the van of course was the lawyer
speaking on behalf of the victim's
family giving a statement on his very
severe medical condition the judge said
yesterday that this could well have been
a murder trial
given the
of injuries of the small boys thrown
from the gallery of the Tate Modern
Building